uh-huh as you all know I'm on a diet and
yes it's a child need a cheeseburger in
front of me and I almost got my ass beat
because I looked at him and said Oh a
long story short his parents thought I
was trying to kidnap him I wasn't I
don't I don't touch babies I just I just
want cheeseburger
[Music]
Oh what is going on you two hmm now
being a part of social media we all know
one true and universal thing almost
everybody has and instagrams Instagram
Instagram
know is what but the problem is
almost everybody has an Instagram now
for Instagram I like to check up on it
every now and then I don't really spend
too much time on it but I do like to
post up just to make ya'll laugh and
keep you updated with my personal life
but recently I decided to really spend
some time with my instagrams and I fell
some weird [ __ ]
specifically weird [ __ ] that people do
on a regular basis so I just got a few
questions to ask so y'all we know what
it is LGI baby let's get let's go how
come your profile picture never looks
like you in real life mmm oh the
deception for example the super angle
profile pic for those of you who don't
know what that is its when you angle a
picture so high it slims down your face
well can I tell you something there's a
limit to that [ __ ] some of you folks out
there take that [ __ ] to an extreme if
you angle that picture anyhow you would
take a picture of your [ __ ] butt
crack
how come every time you take a pic and
there's like you dangling off a cliff
look here's some real advice if your
face isn't slim it ain't slim that's the
real [ __ ] know what you gonna do
Photoshop real life [ __ ] and personally
I hate when this happens
when you go ahead and you reconnect to a
homie through their like Instagram pics
and they look nothing like they do in
the pictures that's what we call a real
life break I like pranks last person
that prank me
scratch them [ __ ] eyes like a
feral cat but you guys know it's true
about half the time when you meet
somebody up through Facebook or
Instagram that you haven't seen in a
while
and you base it off their profile pic
they look nothing like they're doing the
pictures so you will go ahead tell you
about to meet you at Starbucks but you
don't see her all you see is this
creature that looks like she ate Yolanda
for breakfast you're so ashamed of the
way you look don't worry about your
picture boo boo worry about real life
this ain't Simms [ __ ] you can
right-click and save a new face God my
peg why you gonna post quotes they have
nothing to do with the picture huh every
time I scroll through Instagram I have
to see a picture of your [ __ ]
face with a quote they had nothing to do
with your face be safe out there
nature's beautiful 911 remember her
[ __ ] your face has nothing to do with
September 11th if anything your busted
ass face would call the warden the [ __ ]
up my Instagram and then there are those
who always put a biblical foot on the
Instagram that has nothing to do with
the Lord God is good praise Him in all
his glory John 3:16 Oh what that got to
do with Jesus
you know how at that point Jesus be
looking at you like oh my dad it's even
ten times worse when somebody posts a
sunset picture and writes all of God's
creation how do we go and then next week
the picture be like let me suck your
dick [ __ ] I am so sorry I will never
flip my tongue with you like that again
that was it's gonna be your nightmares
why is your selfie always the same
[ __ ] face palm flip it up do
something else but you haven't noticed
this [ __ ] people will make the same
[ __ ] face for 14 different emotions
how does that make sense I'm hungry I'm
sad I have a tummy ache I farted my
butthole itches and we all know why you
put up selfies every day so you can go
ahead and get those thumbs up and add
people tell you that you're beautiful
hey you're [ __ ] beautiful there I
said it you're happy let me tell you
something if I see your face multiple
times it's like having the same food
over and over after a while you just get
[ __ ] Sekhmet I like pizza but I can't
have that [ __ ] every meal
five times the [ __ ] day huh Pizza
face beyond Oh what is going on YouTube
hope y'all enjoyed that bid now I know
there's a lot of people you could send
this video out to because there's a lot
of people that I'm talking about and you
know who they is this is the selfie pose
that everybody does right in the morning
and they quote some stupid [ __ ] on it
but anyways as always if you like that
go-for-broke team once again is that
go-for-broke apparel calm and check out
the previous vlogs on the left or the
right and of course check out the
fitness videos on Wednesday that's right
but anyways people I will see you all in
a couple days because you know fitness
Wednesday is coming up
yup yup yup peace out love you watch me
pick my nose little baby now for me I'm
on this [ __ ] you know a couple times a
day just for your guy's entertainment
and to keep y'all updated with my life
in some shoes another little below that
a little bit of it not like I'm doing
here we go
me me is that he's only cares of the
life